le ministre de la Justice en visite à la
prison de Bois-d'Arcy fervent défenseur
du travail en prison
Eric Dupont-Moretti est venu présenter
le contrat d'emploi pénitentiaire entrée
en vigueur en début d'année je contrat
il est utile pour le détenu qui se forme
qui sort de l'établissement
pénitentiaire avec une expérience
professionnelle
ce contrôle il est utile pour l'ensemble
de notre société parce que mon obsession
c'est la lutte acharnée sans répit
contre la récidive et enfin ce contrat
grâce à la rémunération permet
l'indignisation des victimes avec ce
contrat les détenus sont rémunérés 45%
du SMIC un engagement gagnant-gagnant
pour le détenu et l'entreprise où chacun
y trouve son intérêt je viens aussi pour
donner une chance un syndrome de gens
qui ont besoin qui ont envie de se
réinsérer de leur offrir une deuxième
chance dans de leur faire un emploi de
les former de les embarquer dans une
nouvelle aventure pour ce patron
versaillé dont l'entreprise travaille
exclusivement avec le système carcéral
le travail se fait
direct les murs de la prison on
travaille pour l'industrie automobile
aéronautique cosmétique les imprimeurs
on fait de la sous-traitance voilà on
fait de l'emballage du conditionnement
des titages si aujourd'hui la France
compte 31% de détenus travailleurs
l'objectif du ministère serait à terme
d'atteindre les 50%